the spectator is looking for the UK's
brightest entrepreneurs for our economic
innovator of the Year awards
sponsored by private bank julius baer if
you on a business that brings radical
positive change and is capable of
achieving national or international
impact we want to hear from you apply by
first of July at spectator coat UK
forward slash innovator
[Music]
hello and welcome to spectator outloud
where each week three of our writers
readouts their pieces in the magazine
this week were joined by Kevin Hurley
who is the former police and crime
Commissioner for Surrey and he gives his
opinion on why relations between some
black youths and the police is just so
bad
we're also going to be joined by Alyssia
Moncton who writes about the private
state gap between students during this
lockdown and last James Stirling poll
reviews Alan Bennett's new talking heads
and writes about why he's not such a fan
first up Kevin Hurley I was a borough
commander in West London and come from a
long line of officers and I can tell you
that it's fast becoming impossible to
police the springs the police are
attacked on all sides
they're both told that they're too
aggressive and too politically correct
to understanding and too intolerant
they're required to reduce the level of
violent crime on the street and yet told
their racist if they stop and search
young black men and put hands in pockets
to check for knives as a society we can
shout and scream at the police regulate
them scrutinize them sack of you bring
in external bosses from industry we can
try to re-educate them and have an
independent complaint system but unless
we look clearly at the real problem
Street constables and junior detectives
face every day our cities will soon be
lawless the first thing to understand is
that the police are not a homogeneous
group a response police officer in India
andin has little in common with the
Commissioner of senior officers safe
they wear at similar uniform while both
groups want to think they make a
difference the Chiefs will be thinking
of long term strategies managing budgets
building relationships with other
government officers occasionally they'll
be diverted into thinking about some
fast-moving issue such as the terrorist
event or newspaper critics
at the handling of a major inquiry once
dealing with dynamic events is no longer
their daily business police chiefs can
forget what it's like to be a
superintendent or inspector they want
good press and they have become
calculating and political in the pursuit
of the top job the street cops generally
come from fairly good homes most have
decent education
a lot of them nowadays have been to
university or have done a variety of
jobs before they joined from infantryman
in Afghanistan to nurses or restaurant
managers the majority is still white but
that's no surprise really most of join
due to having had positive exposure to
police officers in the past a surprising
number of police officers are like me
related to other police officers or to
service personnel no one who joins the
police would express a race of view when
being selected or during training to
express such a view in the workplace
would be suicidal to their careers and
would at the very least result in
several of their colleagues turning on
them so why do so many young black
people loathe the police why is there so
much violence it comes down to what in
police circles is known as the Vitara
box of human behavior this describes a
vicious circle your behavior influences
my behavior my behavior influences your
behavior this is how it works
imagine the newly minted PC arriving on
an inner London borough where black on
black stabbings and murders are a
priority together with an experienced
colleague she will approach a pair of
known Street criminals to ask them what
they're doing in a particular location
but as the officers approached the young
men will often start to be abusive
saying
you're only picking on me because I'm
black a big crowd of people within
surround the offices and start to shower
even obstruct them the police will call
for help and help will arrive with
sirens blaring the police will either
dominate or they'll run away withdraw
after such an encounter inevitably
complaints will be made against the
police officers and after a few more
episodes like this
our young officers Bottari box has
become fixed she thinks if I tried to
solve problems and keep the black
community safe I'm accused of bigotry
meanwhile the myth of police racism
continues and the black due to that
incident convinced themselves that they
were picked on in an unjustified search
it's often the best young officers you
become most disillusioned
I remember one young street crime
officer in central London who had a
prolific arrest rate of criminals the
secret of his success was loitering
around Victoria railway station learning
the non suspects faces and observing
carefully it was difficult dangerous and
violent work making arrests in
plainclothes
next to the live rail but it was
rewarding because his 25 most recent
arrests were all black use this officer
was called him by superintendent and
told he was racially biased the officer
replied but most of the muggings and
snatches in this area have been done by
black News the senior officer said
that's not the point I think you need to
go on a racial awareness course the
superintendent put an adverse comment on
the officers file and blocked his
application for promotion the officer
gave up arresting robbers and became an
errand boy for the CID going out and
arresting their
Gouri suspects identified by
fingerprints most burglars are white it
was safe work when I was a borough
commander in West London I asked the
crime analysts to identify the ten most
prolific robbers in the area and the ten
most violent gang members when they've
been identified I stuck the photographs
up on the exit door from the station
into the police vehicle carpark this is
where the PC strength 80 before going on
patrol so my idea was that this way even
the most idle officers would have to
look at and learn the criminals faces
before they went out on patrol then my
senior officer came on what we called a
royal visit he wanted to know how we did
so well at reducing robbery and why we
had no youth murders as I explained our
various tactics and we went out to the
car park door he noticed the twenty
photos and said why have you got all
these black nude pictures stuck up here
you can't do that
it sends the wrong message to any
visitors when I explained my rationale
my boss replied well take them down and
put some white ones up as well but these
are the men identified as the most
high-risk to the public by our civilian
analysts I answered I was told I don't
care
we can't had this take them down when my
boss left I ignored his instructions the
safety of the public was more important
to me though my boss made sure I wasn't
promoted again we remained a top
performing borough we had no youth
murders and my successor soon inherited
the only in a City borough not to face
rioting or looting in 2011 for many
people the idea that the police are
racists fits with their view of history
it's not all unfounded they think of the
abominations suffered at colonial hands
the terrible experiences of the wind
rust generation and the racism of the
1950s and 1960s it's a toxic mix it is
also too often the case now that black
fathers are absent leaving mothers and
grandmothers to bring up the keys often
these women are forced to be away from
the children working all hours in hard
low paid jobs such as carers or cleaners
sometimes doing two jobs or struggling
on benefits is it any wonder that so
many young black boys end up in trouble
so there is no doubt that they suffer
social disadvantages but then so do many
poor white children the result of all of
this is that the police have given up
being inquisitive most people don't
realize the most important quality in a
copper is to be nosy you've got to want
to investigate and get to the bottom of
the problem if police lose their
appetite to investigate this would be a
disaster for black families it would
mean many more mothers would lose their
sons to the knife gun or a lifetime in
prison it would mean that our streets
would become scarier and that County
lines would flourish bringing drugs into
our leafy shires and blighting the lives
of more black children if black lives
really mattered we would change the
conditions that result in this carnage
but we don't that is real institutional
systemic racism that was Kevin Hurley
now Alyssia monkton when Boris Johnson
announced the easing of lockdown this
week there was nothing for schools pubs
yes theme parks even but the education
of children there is no great rush for
that it seems
first things first I have a
fourteen-year-old daughter at a state
grammar and like so many parents I am in
despair the 2-meter rule which had
presented such problems for schools is
finally being relaxed but far from
cheering the move is a crucial step
towards getting children into the
classroom the teaching unions are still
calving advising head teachers to ensure
they have contingency plans for bringing
only half of pupils back on a rotating
basis the prime minister has said all
pupils should return in September but
he's not making it compulsory so parents
are still at the mercy of the unions
indeed following Tuesday's announcement
Jeff Barton of the Association of school
and college leaders maintained the
ambition was pure fantasy
our daughter school has merely said it
is working on the notion of a September
return albeit with an adapted timetable
private schools meanwhile have promised
a full resumption some of hired marquees
for in five prep school pupils are back
in class already during lockdown
they remained pretty well taught
researchers at the Institute of
Education at University College London
recently found that 31 percent of
private schools are providing four or
more online lessons a day just six
percent of state schools do the same 71
percent of state school pupils are
receiving less than an hour's teaching a
day when I learned of these figures I
moved beyond frustration to fury and I
am far from alone you might think a
Grammar School would be keen to maintain
a reputation for academic excellence not
a bit of it at our daughter school
parents have been told the girls should
not be overburdened and that their
well-being must come first
I would suggest that the mental health
of pupils would be far better served by
being fully occupied my daughter has
classmates who claimed not to have
completed a single piece of work since
lockdown began on the 23rd of March
meanwhile a friend
in the same year group who attends a
private school has had a full timetable
online from day one she is at the
computer in uniform every day from 8:30
a.m. every lesson in the curriculum is
delivered online with interactive
feedback then comes a full program of
extracurricular activities including
music master classes arts and crafts and
debating until recently pupils at
Britain's best state schools had been
getting better results than those at the
best private schools lockdown will have
brought an end to this even if Gavin
Williamson or his replacement gets a
grip and all children are able to return
full time in September the focus will be
on the worst-hit the government's
trumpeted 1 billion pound package is
unlikely to benefit the kids who have
been bumping along the richest have had
private schools the poorest will get
extra help but the children of the
squeezed middle will just have to get on
with it those who had expected to be in
direct competition with their privately
educated peers for places at top
universities do not figure in the
discussion
Neil Ross Keely of the Independent
Schools Association tells me they're
getting more and more demands from
parents particularly for places at
primaries and why because no one is in
any doubt that the attainment gap the
source of so much belated hand-wringing
in Whitehall has widened by the week as
professor Francis Green who led that UCL
study concluded everyone is losing out
in this generation but some much more
than others those with the means are
getting the hell out of the state sector
I'm tempted to I've watched our daughter
an only child happier with her own
company the most steadily wither over
these past three months
she needs peer stimulation and the
encouragement and the admonishments of
her teachers the interactions that make
school a school the initial motivation
is long gone she is alternately sad and
frustrated though coping better than
many if my conversation
with other parents or anything to go by
unlike our friends children who had
reportedly been horrified and wholly
resistant to the idea of moving school
at this late stage she is begging us to
explore alternatives it's a momentous
decision to make under pressure and at
such a crucial juncture in her education
not to mention her social development in
a time of instability is it wise to
remove a constant what if she is unhappy
can we afford it but then with another
lockdown being discussed can we afford
not to that was Alyssia Moncton and
finally James Dylan poem the big mistake
people make with alan bennett is to
conflate him with his fellow york
sherman david hockney but whereas
Hockney's art is generous warm bright
life-affirming Bennett's his crabbed
catty dingy insinuating the fact that
the BBC led establishment keeps telling
us he's a national treasure tells us
more about the BBC LED establishment
than it does about Bennett Bennett is
typical of the English intelligentsia
all well anatomized in his the lion and
the unicorn essay open quote it has
always felt that there is something
slightly disgraceful in being an
Englishman and that it is a duty to
snigger at every English institution
from horse racing to suet pudding 'he's
end quote
I'd forgotten quite how much I disliked
Bennett till I was reminded by the BBC's
revival this week of his universally
acclaimed nineteen eighties monologues
Talking Heads no thora Hird this time
obviously but lots of really top-notch
thespian talent
Harry Atwater Sarah Lancashire Martin
Freeman etc going through their paces
dusting down their special accents
meaningful expressions and pregnant
pauses paying homage to the master who
is now 86
the one I particularly hated was one of
the two new ones he's written an
ordinary woman this begins with
Lancashire as an apparently amiable
down-to-earth Yorkshire mum describing
the moment when her fifteen-year-old son
asks her to inspect a worrying spot on
his penis and she realizes that she
actually finds him sexually attractive
is this a common phenomenon personally I
found it
creepy and weird and rather resented
having to spend half an hour of life
listening as on Bennett's behalf
Lancashire rift on this Bizzaro theme
it's a notion that Kate Bush sort of
touched on in her song infant kiss but
at least Bush has the excuse of being
away with the fairies poetically oblique
and oddly innocent with Bennet on the
other hand you get far too much print
detail mum wondering whether on the
other side of the partition wall
dividing their bedrooms her
fifteen-year-old son is less debating
and getting aroused by the idea of it
they say that as civilizations collapse
as ours is now the intellectual elite
become morbidly obsessed with the
decadent and perverse you'd really need
to be a BBC commissioning editor I think
or a theatrical loving like the director
who oversaw this project Nicholas Hytner
to greet a TV monologue half celebrating
or at least not wholly condemning
maternal incest with anything other than
a ten-foot barge pole and I'm not buying
the defense that Bennet is merely
inhabiting the minds of the marginalized
and the downtrodden there's one of his
throwaway lines at the end except of
course with Bennet noting his throw away
where the mother takes a pill to cure
her condition because it's open quotes
makes you indifferent to one another
like families normally our end quote
but our family is normally indifferent
to one another only in the imaginations
of the jaded the sick and the marxist
I'd say perhaps Bennet himself had a
disappointing upbringing which we know
got over I don't know but if I were his
psychiatrist I'd find reams of material
the querulous gay mentally ill character
in a chip in the sugar played by Bennett
himself in the original version and in
this one by Martin Freeman all but
imprisoned with his mother like Tony
last forced to read Dickens to mr. Todd
for all eternity and in soldiering on
the widow and doting mother played by
Harriet Walter still utterly besotted
with the vile son who won't visit her
and who has reduced her to a joyless
penurious existence broadening on
daytime TV open quote I wouldn't want
you to think this was a tragic story I'm
not a tragic woman not that type waters
is indomitable stiff upper-lip in this
woman tells us at the end of that
particular monologue but the irony is
bitter and unconsolable despises his
characters and the Englishness they
embody more than he loves them take the
relish with which he sets up the
character of the antique dealer played
by kristin scott thomas who spends the
first half telling us what a good eyes
she has and how wise she is to all the
tricks of the trade and the second ruin
the potential millions she has lost
giving away for a song a Raphael drawing
her expert I failed to identify her
mistake of course was to have been a
hard-working decent member of the
English bourgeoisie had she been a
smelly old [ __ ] lady in a van Bennett
would have treated her to her
hagiography don't get me wrong I'm fully
alive to the charm and wit and fluency
at Bennett's writing the way he captures
so perfectly the ticks and Cadence's of
spoken English though he's better at
doing Yorkshire folk than he is his
somewhat caricatured upper middle
classes and I do think the history boys
the madness have George the third and
Wind in the Willows make great nights
out but the politics the bitchiness and
the misanthropy underneath are pure
poison that was James Dylan Paul thanks
for listening to this episode of
spectator
ploud and do join us again next week I
remember a few days subscribe to the
magazine already you can do so by going
to spectator Koike forward slash voucher
in order to get a 20 pound Amazon
voucher as well as a subscription
[Music]
the spectator is looking for the UK's
brightest entrepreneurs for our economic
innovator of the Year awards
sponsored by private bank julius baer if
you on a business that brings radical
positive change and is capable of
achieving national or international
impact we want to hear from you apply by
first of July at spectator coat UK
forward slash innovator innovator
innovator